Disney musicals have been making kids
dance laugh and cry for generations and
if you look closely you'll see there's a
method to the magic technique
songwriters use over and over again to
make Disney songs sound uniquely Disney
so we're going to be writing a song with
the help from my friend Ally Smither
that's hopefully worthy of being the
next Disney hit if you want to write the
next big Disney hit the first thing you
need to consider is in the music it's
the story sure these songs need to be
entertaining but they also have a
function if your song isn't moving the
story from point A to B it'll likely end
up on the cutting room floor even one of
the most popular Disney songs of all
time almost never made it to the screen
where the people are Jeffrey Katzenberg
the head of Disney's motion picture
division at the time thought part of
your worlds from the 1989 hit The Little
Mermaid was slowing down the story too
much the writers then sprinkled in a
little crab comedy to give the sea any
more energy saving the now classic
Disney song but part of your world is
also doing some work it's a perfect
example of one of the main song types
that appear almost every time songs and
storylines come together which is the I
wants a song because if a story is gonna
move someone has to want something right
like Broadway musicals Disney musicals
use a similar set of song types in every
film there's usually an intro song which
introduces a few main characters and
tells the audience exactly where they
are
and every hero needs a villain and every
villain needs a good villain song Disney
also seems to love songs about work
whether it's Snow White singing whistle
while you work or Mary Poppins with her
spoonful of sugar work songs are
everywhere
they even parodied the practice in their
2007 film enchanted so how our Disney
song is able to do all that storytelling
work in under two hours they do more
with less when you only have room for a
handful of songs in each film you better
make sure those songs work as well as
your pedals cuckoo clock Disney doesn't
have as much time to dwell on its
lyrical hooks as a typical pop song take
one song that's been at the top of the
charts lately post Malone and sway Lee's
sunflower understand in the first
quatrain not only is the word rec
repeated to rhyme with itself the entire
pot range is repeated you'll never see a
dizzy song spend this much time on one
thought it just doesn't happen
repetition isn't new one pop music check
out billboards top 100 single of all
time the twist by Chubby Checker they're
only 48 unique words in the 145 Warsaw
how does dizzy squeeze more from less
with their song forms well they cut out
the chorus dizzy songs often use
refrains or title hooks instead of a
full chorus cutting out the chorus
leaves much more room for a variety of
first lyrics more lyrics equals more
information and more information equals
more story another way Disney trims it
song forms down is by cutting already
established sections in half so let's
say the first time we hear a verse is 16
bars the next time we hear it it's only
8 sneaky right look for this in songs
like once upon a dream a whole new world
or even breaking free from high school
musical
of course why find sections to trim in
half when you can just bright super
short sections to begin with like in the
bridge of colors of the wind
it's a scant five bars long a 5 bar
bridge in a pop tune is almost unheard
of most pop songs and most songs in
general have steady tempos throughout
but Disney disproportionately changes
tempo and even meter in their music take
the song Winnie the Pooh it starts off
in 3/4 time deep in the Hundred Acre
Wood but by the time we get to Winnie
the Pooh Winnie the Pooh that's 4/4 time
the song be our guests from 1991's
Beauty and the Beast uses 5 different
tempos you find me a song on the radio
that uses 5 different tempos no
discussion of Disney rhythm would be
complete without mentioning the novelty
speed up ending as using countless songs
such as fixer-upper from frozen or in
the classic supercalifragilistic
expialidocious busy songs use a lot of
chords around double the number of
different chords used by your average
pop song one study of the 70 top disney
songs of all time averaged over eight
types of triads use per song so in any
given key there are seven diatonic
chords
diatonic meaning that the notes involved
stay within the scale let's take this
song for example
[Music]
the a major is a non diatonic cord if we
were to reimagine this tune using only
diatonic chords
it might sound something like this and
if you're writing a Disney hit you'll
probably want to throw in a key change
Disney songs averaged just over one key
change per song if you compare that to
the Rolling Stone top 500 songs of all
time
Disney songs are 10 times more likely to
contain a key change this matches pretty
well with how things are always changing
in Disney movies such as pumpkins
turning into carriages puppets into real
boys and princes into frogs the
difference between the Disney song and a
pop song becomes clear when you compare
two versions of the hit Disney song let
it go from frozen the Disney film
version sung by idina menzel and the pop
music version sung by Demi Lovato first
the film version key changes check with
for changes in the tonal center whole
lot of chords yep
11 core types not including modulations
well north of our eight-point-five quota
the cut in half verse got it there's
even a mini novelty speed-up motif when
Elsa starts building her ice castle
now let's explore how the song changed
when they ran it through the pop song
ringer he changes all gone hold on a
core types trim down from 11 - just for
that half verse homogenous and the mini
novelty speed up yeah they they let it
go and remember the difference between
pop lyrics and Disney Demi's pop version
uses the phrase let it go 26 times in
the movie version Elsa sings let it go
only 12 times
Demi's pop version employs 106 unique
words in the movie version Elsa sings
136 unique words all while crossing the
finish line a few seconds earlier should
we pick one song type what if you just
did a yearning song what we want
what are we wanting to win over just one
more subscribers that's okay I'm busily
animated right now like look at me just
one more okay how we're gonna do this
without any lyrics let's gonna sing her
to see it so okay I need help with
filling in the lyrics and also finishing
the melody
maybe it's like just one just one more
subscriber also what about a lion serve
in the realms of will you be a
subscriber but I know you're out there
so won't you be my subscriber won't use
my connection won't you be my neighbor
just just one more subscriber just one
connection just
I have these tools these ideas these
hopes and
sometimes I feel but the world is wide
and I know with hopes
[Music]
you know what this reminds me of I'll
just say sappy Korean drama you know
what it means all of these chord changes
and all of these lyrics are very earnest
bye
nice to meet you are
[Music]